(tiny bleep)
- Can you make the hairs
go in one direction?
- I'm trying to, but I'm
trying to give it, like,
a posing pattern.
- Just go in one direction.
- Wow, what do we have here?
Monsters twink?
(laughing)
- Uh, no?
For your information, we're
going to Concert Fest.
- Too cool for the
likes of you, Betsy.
Or should I call
you "the Comish"?
(laughing)
(smooches)
- We may not be cool enough
to get over priced heatstroke,
but Cornell and I were sneaking
into IMAX movies all day.
I'm the human snackbar.
- Woah, where's
the fire, two-eyes?
- I'm gonna spend the weekend
at my girlfriend's house.
Things have gotten a
little tense around here.
(dramatic guitar chord)
- Coyote!
Thought it was the mailman!
- What?
- Like coyote in the house!
(ravenous snarling)
- Oh my god, he's right!
Everyone run!
There's a coyote in the house!
(screaming)
- Guys, split up!
It can only eat some of us.
(screaming)
(dramatic music)
(whooshing)
- Animal control says
they have to pick up
a snake, a raccoon, and a
possum before they get to us.
- Now that sounds
like a fun car, right?
- Let's just hang tight here
and we will be fine.
- Wait a minute, who
made you leader, huh?
I don't see your
butt-boy Nick anywhere.
- Okay, don't be jealous
'cause I'm a born leader.
People trust me,
they're scared of you.
- What? You guys
talkin' behind my back?
- Because I have files
with all of your
grandmothers' information.
Huh?
(horrified gasp)
(dramatic tone)
- Cal!
Hey buddy, hang in there,
'cause a lot of
people care about you,
and they really, really
need you in their lives.
(smacking)
- God dammit!
Now I'm gonna miss my
fun concert day with Cal,
because of you!
- What? I didn't let
a coyote in the house.
- Yeah, but we were
just about to leave,
and then you started talking
about your dumb girlfriend,
and we felt bad for you,
'cause you're so lame.
- (Mumbling), man.
What's your fucking
problem with me?
- Oh, I think you know what
my problem is with you.
- (frustrated sigh)
Maybe you're jealous?
Because you have an unhealthy,
codependency with Cal?
(laughs, scoffs)
- No.
In fact, ever since
you've moved in,
I've been super jealous,
'cause I'm dependent
on Cal for a lot of things.
(stomach gurgles dangerously)
- Ah, guys, uh.
Okay, I ate a bad
GoGurt, and I gotta go.
Now.
(dramatic tone)
- You're such a
benevolent leader,
so long as everybody
does what you say.
- Yeah.
- Is that why Nick got a
tattoo of your face on his ass?
- It was a hot brand!
- That's worse than a tattoo!
- I love him!
That's not awful!
(Betsy yelling indistinctly)
People love me!
(both arguing indistinctly)
- Will you guys please, please,
would you just go
ahead and do it?
- [Both] What?
- I'm serious.
I saw this
documentary on NatGeo,
and it showed how
heightened human pheromones
can scare away predators.
Now if you guys are
willing to put aside
your differences and
do the stinky deed,
we might get out of this.
(dramatic tone)
(groaning)
- Alright.
Hang in there,
Corny, come on, man.
(panting, groaning)
(screams in pain)
- Hey, hey!
Hey, who's a pretty boy?
(whimpering)
- Will you give me
another GoGurt, man?
- Yeah, yeah.
- No. No.
- Right, no, man, just,
look, I know you gotta
poop real bad, okay?
But just hang in there,
there's a ravenous
coyote outside, okay?
You're gonna have to
ride this one out.
(gentle sobbing)
Wait.
(dramatic music)
He needs to fart.
- What?
- Fart? Pass gas? Toot?
- Yeah, man, I know
what a fart is.
- Well he's got a poop in there.
And there's pressure
building up behind it,
so we gotta relieve it somehow.
If we can coerce a fart
out around the poop,
not through it, around it,
without breaking the poop up,
we may have a chance
of saving him.
I'm gonna need some help.
Oh!
I'm kidding, yeah,
I need your help.
(dramatic music)
- Yeah, I would never
have sex with you.
Even if you were wearing
a Liam Neeson mask.
- Well I would never
have sex with you,
even if you were the mom of...
Wait a second.
We have to do this.
We were friends once.
- You're right.
If we wanna be the
leaders of this house,
we have to act like it.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
I want you to put
your dick inside me.
- I'm gonna put it in,
I'm gonna slide it right in!
- Put it inside of me!
(screaming)
- [Cornell] Ow, ow!
- Stay with me, Cornell.
Cornell, stay with me.
Stay with me.
(synth music)
(screaming in pain)
♪ Be my everyday
♪ Savior
(screaming in pleasure)
(howling)
- Get it out, man!
Get it out!
(screams)
(farts)
(panting)
(relieved laughing)
(sighing)
- We have the animal
under control,
you can all come out now.
(relieved groans)
- Thank God.
- What a day, right?
- Wow.
- Thank you, and
thank all of you.
(gentle guitar)
Especially Betsy,
who I just had sex with.
You know, I never realized--
- Do I have to be here for this?
- Yes.
All we needed to get along
was just to get to
know each other.
- Looks like that
coyote turned out
to be quite the
blessing after all.
(gentle laughter)
- Oh, that wasn't
a coyote. (laughs)
It was the next-door
neighbor's dog.
His head got stuck
in the radiator
and we had to put 'er down.
(horrified gasps)
- Well, this is
everyone's fault but mine.
- What?
- It is only your fault.
- How is it my fault?
- Everyone was on edge.
(all furiously arguing)
(thumps)
(gentle guitar)
(heavy dance music)